and now we put it all together if you
missed the last four episodes check them
out link below
but for those of you who have it let's
check out how to get started with
kubernetes
with a whole universe of things to learn
it's important to start with the
essentials
let's go over the concepts that make
kubernetes usable scalable and just
downright
awesome are you ready hey caslin thanks
for joining me in this culminating video
before we talked about containers and
some other things but it was mostly
theoretical
it would be great to see an example in
action what do you think
yeah sounds good to me you remember in
the last episodes how we talked about
containers and deploying those
containers onto kubernetes
yeah i went back i rewatched all the old
episodes we talked about nodes we talked
about containers and we even talked
about the basic kubernetes
api objects but one thing was we
deployed everything imperatively
which you said wasn't going to scale
well right
right so this time i'm going to show you
how to deploy
an app declaratively great i can't wait
to see how it works
now we're going to explore how to deploy
applications in containers declaratively
using kubernetes
if you remember in the last video we
talked about deployments in kubernetes
and how to create them
but the command that we used in our last
video
to create a deployment was imperative we
told kubernetes exactly what we wanted
it to do
and it did it in the real world we don't
really want to do things that way
we want to do things declaratively by
having a file that describes or
declares what we want things to be like
and then we have kubernetes do the hard
work of figuring out how to make that
happen
having our state defined declaratively
in files allows us to do some cool
things
like make changes to our deployments by
just changing the file describing it
we can also track those changes through
source control
and make use of great tools for
deploying applications at scale like
continuous integration and continuous
deployment tools
so to start with let's create a
deployment like we did in the last video
but this time we'll do it declaratively
so here you can see that i'm in google
cloud platform
and i'm using the cloud shell terminal
to interact with a kubernetes cluster
that i have already created
and if i run ls here you'll see that i'm
in a directory that has
some subdirectories and some files
so the files for my microservice
application
that i'm going to need to create that
microservice application in kubernetes
are all
in these directories so the first one
that i'm going to look at
is deployments hello.yaml
so in this case i have all of my files
separated by the type of kubernetes
resource that they
define you could do this in all sorts of
ways you don't have to do it with this
structure or anything
it's just the way that it is here so
let's take a look at this
if you remember the last video we had to
tell kubernetes
what it was that we wanted it to create
which is a deployment in this case so
we're doing that again here
we're giving that deployment a name
we're telling kubernetes a number of
replicas
that we want of the pods that will be in
this deployment
if you remember that we went over those
as well and
so here we're defining the actual
containers that we're going to be
running the container image
and a bit more information about that
and you'll also see down here we have a
liveness probe and a readiness probe
which we didn't really go over last time
but they are tools that kubernetes
provides to help make sure that your
application is up and ready to receive
traffic uh so there's a bit more that
you can learn about deployments
as you can see this is a fairly uh
it's not really that long but there are
a few components in it that are worth
learning a bit more about
so if you want to look into deployments
a bit more i would recommend it
so this is what we mean by declaring
our desired state all of the information
about what we want this deployment to
look like is here in this file
and if we wanted to make a change like
changing the image
that we're going to be running in this
deployment we could do that in this file
and we could track that change through
source control
so the next thing i'm going to do
actually i want to look at one more
file before i create anything
so let me look at within services i have
another file called hello.yaml
so if you remember from the last video
we created our deployment
with our application but then we needed
some way to reach our application
and we did that by creating a kubernetes
service
so this is uh what this is going to do
this is creating another kubernetes
service that will allow us to connect
to our hello application which will be
deployed in its own deployment
so this service definition is pretty
simple
it just has a name for the service it
has a selector which tells the service
how to find the back-ends that it is
serving
and then it has some port information
that will allow us to actually reach
that application
so if i want to create these and i
wanted to do it in a
declarative way what i'm going to do is
run cube ctl
apply dash f and give it the file name
so let's say deployments hello.yaml
and i can do more than one at a time i
can just add another dash f here
and specify my service and create my
service at the same time
so that's pretty cool the cube ctl apply
command doesn't
know which api object you're creating so
you can
specify it in the file and then just
give it those files
so it's pretty versatile so let's go
ahead and create those so you can see
that my deployment
and my service were created but it
wouldn't be a micro service application
if it wasn't split up into
multiple services so the next service
that i'm going to deploy
i'm going to deploy in exactly the same
way i'm going to do cube ctl
apply dash f and then
grab another deployment and this time
i'm going to deploy my
front end yml so for this
application i've added in an nginx
server
which will act as my front end and by
the way if you want to try this stuff
out for yourself
and follow along or just kind of play
around with it
check out the links below we'll have
some information for you to get hands-on
with this
so we're going to run cube ctl apply
and we'll give it the file for our
front-end deployment
and once again we're going to need a
service for that
so let's create our front-end
yaml service as well
now an interesting thing here is i'm
using the cube ctl
apply command because
if that resource doesn't exist the apply
command will go ahead and create the
resource
so i didn't have a front-end deployment
or
a front-end service before so it went
ahead and created those but if i were to
run this command
again you'll see that it says that the
front-end
and uh the deployment and its service
were
unchanged so if we were to make a change
to our deployment
like i said earlier if we were to update
the uh
container image or something like that
in our deployment
file where we have declared what we want
our deployment to look like
then we would be able to just apply that
change
and in the case of deployments there are
settings
within kubernetes that you can use to
tell it how to roll
out that change when you apply a new
change uh
so in that way this is a very
declarative way
uh to create resources in kubernetes
but now that i have an nginx component
to my application
there are some configuration
there's some configuration information
that i want to pass into my nginx server
and it didn't really make sense to add
that stuff into the
container definition and it didn't
really make sense to add that at any
point along the way
in creating the kubernetes deployment so
how am i going to get that configuration
information into my nginx server now
luckily kubernetes has a tool for that
called configmaps
a config map lets you map your
configuration
information to your application running
in a kubernetes deployment
i already have a file here which has
the configuration information that i
need for my nginx front-end and it's in
nginxfrontend.com so you can see here
that this is a bunch of configuration
information
for my nginx front end but you'll see
that it's not in yaml farm
so this is not actually declaratively
declared so i'm going to have to create
this
just using the configuration file as it
is so what i'm going to do is run cube
ctl create
config map is the type of
kubernetes object that i want to create
and i'm going to give that a name
which i'm just going to call it nginx
front end
conf and i'm going to tell it i want it
to create that config map
from a file with information
[Music]
file which is
nginx slash frontend.com
cool so this will go ahead and create
the config map from that configuration
information that i showed you a minute
ago
but i have another problem i want to run
this application a bit more securely
and i want to use tls with it
but for that i'm going to need to pass
it some tls certs
which i don't really want to pass in a
config map because that information
is just kind of plain text i want to
make sure that that information is kept
more well secret so kubernetes has a
great tool for this
called secrets now there are a lot of
different tools for passing
sensitive information in kubernetes so
kubernetes secrets might not be the best
tool for your use case
you'll have to do a little bit of
research to figure it out
but in my case kubernetes secrets are
gonna be just fine
they'll encrypt the information that i'm
passing into my application so let's go
ahead and create a secret
to pass my uh application the tls certs
that i have for it
so cubectl create is what i'm going to
use again
secrets are very similar to config maps
except they're for
secret information so create a secret
and there are a few different types of
secrets but for this one i'm just going
to create a generic one
and i'm going to give it a name tls
certs
and i'm going to create that once again
from a file
and that will be the tls search
that i have in my directory so
that secret was created and now there's
one more piece of my microservice
application
and that is an authentication
tool that i've added into the
microservice
so what that's going to look like is
once again coming back to that
trusty cube ctl apply dash f
and i'm going to grab a service
for my auth.yaml component of my
microservice
and of course i'm going to need
something for that service to serve
which will be a deployment once again
and
that's going to be auth.yaml as well
and i appear to have mistyped something
oh i didn't put a dash f before my
deployments
file so you do have to put a dash f for
each file that you're passing it so
there you go
you can see that i've gone ahead and
created the service and the deployment
for my
authentication component of my
microservice
and that's it that's my whole
microservice that i'm going to be
showing you today
but how do i make sure that it's working
properly well the best way is always to
test right so i'm going to run cube ctl
get services or just sbc for short
and i want to get the information for my
front end so you'll see that my front
end
service is of type load balancer in this
case that means that it created
an actual load balancer resource in
google cloud
and that external kind of load balancer
resource
has created an external ip for us that
we will actually be able to
use to reach the application that i've
created
so i'm going to copy that ip and i'm
going to export it as a variable just to
make my following commands a little bit
easier
next eternal
ip and give it that number
okay so i've created my variable so now
i can
run a curl command to test to make sure
that my application is running correctly
and if you'll remember earlier we
incorporated some security capabilities
into this application
but let's say that i just curled uh that
that ip what would happen
actually i'm just gonna paste it in even
though i just did that
so if i curl that nothing happens why is
that
of course it's because we uh set up tls
and we set up
some security measures so now we're
going to have to connect to this
application
using https a bit more securely
so i'm going to run curl dash k
uh https colon slash
and give it that ip and there you go
so we've got our message output of
hello and that's all i expected this
application to do so i know that the
application is
up and running properly but i also
incorporated this
authentication capability and so i can
also connect to this
application as a specific user and
make use of it that way so for that i'm
going to have to get a token
to log in as a specific user so what
that's going to look like
i already did it so i'm gonna go ahead
and enter the password for the user
so what you can see here is i set up a
token
which uh equals a curl command
logging in as a specific user i'm
grabbing the the token from that login
i had to enter the password for that
user and so now i have this
token that i can use to access the
website as well
so now i'm going to go ahead and run a
curl command
where i am passing in that token so i'm
logging in as a specific
user and if i run that i get the same
result
so i know that i can reach my
application
uh by using this authorization
capability that i edited
so cool stuff i went through and i
created deployments and config maps
and secrets and for
the deployments and the services i did
it in a declarative way
using these files that i can then go in
and make changes to
track those changes and do a lot of
really cool stuff with
automation and running applications at
scale so this is going to be really
useful
great so that's how i can run my
application declaratively
right running things declaratively is
really useful in the real world
running your deployments based on a file
makes it easy to set up ci cd
source control and other processes that
are useful for running applications at
scale
wow thanks to caslin for taking the time
to show me how this all works
this wraps up the most basic kubernetes
objects next time we'll start looking
into more advanced use cases and
features of kubernetes
stay tuned oh and be sure to follow
along in the codelab link below to walk
through this code if you want to get
hands on
and if you enjoyed this episode
subscribe for more
you